this is jocko podcast number 297 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
i was walking through washington square
when a puff of smoke issuing from the
factory building caught my
eye i reached the building before the
alarm was turned in
i saw every feature of the tragedy
visible from outside the building
i learned a new sound
a more horrible sound than description
can picture
it was the thud of a speeding living
body
on a stone sidewalk
thud
dead thud dead
thud dead
62 thud
deads
i call them that because the sound and
the thought of death came to me each
time at the same instant
there was plenty of chance to watch them
as they came down
the height was 80 feet
the first 10 thud deads shocked me
i looked up
[Music]
saw that there were scores of girls at
the windows
the flames from the floor below were
beating in their faces
somehow i knew that they too must come
down
and something within me
something that i didn't know was there
stealed me
i even watched one girl falling waving
her arms trying to keep her body upright
until the very instant she struck the
sidewalk
she was trying to balance herself
then came the thud
a silent unmoving pile of clothing and
twisted broken limbs
as i reached the scene of the fire a
cloud of smoke hung over the building
i looked up to the seventh floor
there was a living picture in each
window four screaming heads of girls
waving their arms
call the firemen they screamed scores of
them get a ladder cried others
they were all as alive and whole and
sound as were we who stood on the
sidewalk
i couldn't help thinking of that
we cried to them not to jump
we heard the siren of a fire engine in
the distance
the others the other sirens sounded from
several directions here they come we
yell don't jump stay there
one girl climbed out on the window sash
those behind her tried to hold her back
then she dropped into space
i didn't notice whether those above
watched her drop because i had turned
away
then came that first thud
i looked up another girl was climbing
onto the windowsill
others were crowding behind her she
dropped
i watched her fall again the dreadful
sound
two windows away two girls were climbing
onto the sill they were fighting each
other and crowding for air
behind them i saw many screaming heads
they almost fell together
but i heard two distinct thuds
then the flames burst out of the windows
on the floor below them
and curled up into their faces
the firemen began
to raise a ladder
others took out a life net and while
they were rushing to the sidewalk with
it two more girls shot down
the firemen held it under them
the bodies broke it
the grotesque
simile of a dog jumping through a hoop
struck me
they could move the net
another girl's body flashed through it
the thuds were just as loud
it seemed as if there had been no net
there
it seemed to me that the thuds were so
loud that they might have been heard all
over the city
i had counted ten
then my dulled senses began to work
automatically
noticed things that it had not occurred
to me before to notice little details
that the first shock had blinded me to
i looked up to see whether those above
watched those who fell
i noticed that they did
they watched them every inch of the way
down and probably heard the roaring
thuds that we heard
as i looked up i saw a love affair in
the midst of all the horror
a young man helped a girl to the
windowsill
then he held her out deliberately away
from the building
and let her drop
he seemed cool and calculating he held
out a second girl the same way
and let her drop
then he held out a third girl who did
not resist i noticed that
they were as unresisting as if you were
helping them onto a streetcar instead of
into eternity
undoubtedly he saw that a terrible death
awaited them in the flames
and his was only a terrible chivalry
then came the love amid the flames he
brought another girl to the window those
of us who were looking
saw her put her arms about him and kiss
him
then he held her out into space and
dropped her
but quick as a flash
he was on the windowsill himself
his coat fluttered upward the air filled
his trouser legs
i could see that he wore tan shoes and
hoes
his hat remained on his head
thud dead
together they went into eternity
i saw his face before they covered it
you could see in it that he was a real
man
he had done his best
we found out later
that in the room which he stood many
girls were being burned to death by the
flames and were screaming in an inferno
of flame and heat
he chose the easiest way and was brave
enough to even help the girl he loved to
a quicker death
after she had given him a goodbye kiss
he leaped with an energy as if to arrive
first in that mysterious land of
eternity
but her thud dead came first
the firemen raised the longest ladder
it reached only to the sixth floor
i saw the last girl jump
and miss it
and then the faces disappeared from the
window
but now the crowd was enormous
though all this had occurred in less
than seven minutes the start of the fire
and the thuds and the deaths
i heard screams around the corner and
hurried there
what i had seen before
was not so terrible as what followed
up in the ninth floor
girls were burning to death before our
very eyes
they were jammed in the windows
no one was lucky enough to be able to
jump it seemed
but one by one the jams broke down came
the bodies in a shower burning smoking
flaming bodies with disheveled hair
trailing upward
they'd fought each other to die by
jumping instead of fire
the whole
sound
unharmed girls who had jumped on the
other side of the building had tried to
fall feet down
but these fire tortures suffering ones
fell inertly
only intent that death should come to
them on the sidewalk instead of in the
furnace behind them
on the sidewalk lay heaps of broken
bodies
a policeman later went about with tags
which he fastened with wires to the
wrists of the dead girls numbering each
with a lead pencil
and i saw him fasten tag number 54 to
the wrist of a girl who wore an
engagement ring
a fireman who came down the stairs from
the building told me that there were at
least 50 bodies in the big room on the
seventh floor
another fireman told me that more girls
had jumped down the air shaft at the
rear of the building
i went back there
into the narrow court and saw heaps of
dead girls
the floods of water from the fireman's
hose that ran into the gutter were
actually stained red with blood
i looked upon the heap of dead bodies
and i remembered these girls were shirt
waste makers
i remembered their great strike of last
year in which these same girls had
demanded more sanitary conditions and
more safety precautions in the shops
these dead bodies were the answer
and that is
an article a first-person account
obviously
about the nightmare of a fire
at the triangle shirt waste company in
greenwich village new york city
and the story came from united press
reporter william shepherd who happened
to be there
just watching the disaster unfold and
who phoned in the details
to a young newspaper employee by the
name of roy howard who telegraphed the
story to the nation's newspapers and
that article
was first published in the milwaukee
journal march 27 1911.
and the fire killed 146 garment workers
123 women
23 men
the oldest victim was 43 years old the
youngest 14 years old
many were recent italian or jewish
immigrants
and part of the reason that they were up
there even as this fire consumed the
building is that many of the doors to
the stairwells and the exit doors in the
factory were locked shut
in order to prevent
workers from
taking unauthorized breaks or stop them
from maybe
stealing some of the goods that they
were making
just a complete nightmare
and we try and find some
some good in that story if there is any
to be found
it's that that fire led to eventual
improvements of safety standards
in these types of factories
and
this singular event
was a catalyst for massive growth growth
of the international ladies garment
workers union
that union got together
and fought and were successful in
improving
working conditions in these types of
swept shops
and over time in america these
conditions did improve
and
this is also a story of
the
incredible sacrifices that
american workers have made over time to
build this great country and to build
our great economy
and if you look universally you can see
improvements in the conditions that
people work in in america but we have to
remember that there are other areas of
the world
that have not made any of these
improvements
and much of the
labor conditions overseas
especially when it comes to the garment
industry is the conditions are still
brutal
there's a group called
anti-slavery international
and they report that about a fifth of
the cotton production
in the world can be linked to forced
labor
for example much of the forced labor in
china those are
ethnic uighurs
those are the those are the slaves over
in china no safety training no safety
protocol
exposure to harmful chemical bad air
extreme work hours nine to 12 hours a
day six days a week
it's bad
conditions that are illegal
in this country
but
it's the standard overseas in many
places
and why am i talking about this because
well because we have been trying to do
something about it and we actually have
been doing something about it
for a few years
who's we it's well it's myself
and the rest of the
incredible team including
the team that actually works the
machines at origin usa
incredible
group
that gets this work done
and takes pride in this work
and the team at origin usa and jocko
fuel
is who's making a difference right now
and that includes
my main partner
in these two endeavors
peter roberts
and he is here once again
to get us up to date
on this fight
this fight
to
improve the condition of manufacturing
and bring it back to america where we
have
a positive
work environment
we have a good work environment we have
a work environment where when you walk
the floors
you have people with pride and smiles on
their faces
in the job that they're doing
so
pete
thanks for coming back man
um it's been a while
happy to be back it's been way too long
well if you haven't listened to so you
you first came on the podcast was
podcast 93 you were on podcast 93
podcast 141 podcast 94. those are about
a year apart each september 2017
september 2018 september 2019 is when
they came out we recorded them all in
late august which is right now
late august 2021 we're recording this
we we've recorded all of them at the
origin jiu jitsu camp immersion camp up
here in maine
and we didn't record last year at all
because it was the year of covet 2020
and so we didn't do camp yep
did i even did i come up what i came up
one time in 2020 for some reason didn't
i i don't think i don't think so because
no because you would have seen the
expanded facilities oh that's right i
came out and saw you in montana that's
right and i came out saw you in
california just at the beginning march
of 2020 for the vitamin shop launch i
must have come out right before covet
hit because i remember being up here in
the winter because we were walking
through the snow yeah that's right we
were walking through the downturn right
down high street yeah
and
yeah so i knew i must have been right
before kobe it must have been yeah
um
but if you haven't listened to those
podcasts if you want to know why pete's
here if you want to know how we ended up
joining forces and doing what we're
doing go back and listen to 93 141 than
194. if you've listened to those if
you've been tracking if you've heard any
of uh echo
charles yes talking about various
[Music]
various gear to purchase
then this is what we've been talking
about so you probably are somewhat aware
of the situation that's going on um but
a lot has happened last two years since
we did a podcast
and just wanted to talk bring you on
talk about what we've been doing
the progress we've made the setbacks
we've had the lessons that we've learned
and where we're planning to go from here
i mean
what's when you think about 2021 and i
mean 2020 and everyone you know big
negative on 2020 everyone hated it etc
all kinds of issues but heading into
2020 coming out of 2019 we had a ton of
really positive momentum a lot of
positive growth
things were kind of on a really solid
track trajectory was looking outstanding
and so that was we were in a pretty good
place now
we also had some
missteps i know you like to call them
tuition payments yes
we did make some tuition payments last
time last time i was on i filled you in
on the jeans tuition payment remember we
did that real time yeah what was it had
to make like 500 pairs of jeans before
we got them right yep that grew a little
bit we have been
we have been
struggling
with uh and we paid some tuition
payments on mulc bars we did and
you know actually when you were when you
were reading that i couldn't stop but
you know i couldn't help but think about
my my great yaya and she was an
immigrant from
from sparta greece so yeah yeah is greek
is that just like your personal nickname
is that everybody know everybody that's
greek has it you call me just throwing
out yaya around here yeah i know
i'm american
she lived to uh she lived to 105. so my
in my kids got to meet her
um
is that the aunt of that's the mother of
my aunt kaye who just turned 90 you sent
that video to no your mom's in the
you're you're my great aunt yes she's in
the game oh yeah she's in the game she
loves you she's like oh she's listening
to this podcast right now like oh if i
ever get to meet you i've got to put
that makeup on i got to make sure i look
good it's just turned 90.
and so she um has trusted me with uh
it's really with a crocheted blanket
that my my great yaya was a like a low
mil girl so she worked in these mills
you speak of
as an immigrant in the very early 1900s
in lowell massachusetts and she's this
is this story took place in 1911 exactly
and that's i was thinking about this the
whole time she used to pick up the
skinners like the little bit of yarn and
she'd
she'd take it home with her and she'd
she'd crochet and make blankets and
stuff
so you have one of those in my office
yeah i got it uh
she said they might have been been
during
last year at some point she she's
shipped it up to me she'd been trying to
figure out who she should give it to and
trust it too basically then she saw that
you had a freaking loom
so i've got it i've got it up in there
what an incredible thread of personal
history yeah
i'm gonna frame it at some point when we
build a massive new factory it'll be
hanging in the front lobby that's that's
that's like incredible so that story is
that's yaya could have been exactly
that's what i was thinking about like
the working conditions of course
have improved since then but when people
ask me
like why why would someone want to work
in a factory
i think about well you know i i
i talk about my grandparents and great
grandparents who all worked in factories
tanneries and mills
and they always said to their kids our
parents the baby boomers
don't work in the factories but they
always romanticized about working in the
factories and i never could figure out
why did why did they romanticize about
it and always reflect on it but then
tell their kids not to do it
i didn't understand until right now
that's why because the generation before
them their parents were
dealing with [ __ ] like that yeah you
know just terrible working conditions
hot bare feet
the woman up in lewiston maine rachel
degrozier she told me a story about the
bates mill in lewiston where we got our
first loom from
and she said one of the girls
used to run
up the hill for her shift and her sister
would run down the hill and she'd pass
her shoes off
and then she'd come down into the mill
and work and it was just
survival
yeah so not only was it hard work but
you didn't have enough money to buy a
pair of shoes exactly
and what's really interesting about this
is
like we were up at the factory the other
day at the boot plant
very awesome isn't it and andy was
telling a story andy who oversees all
that production yeah he was telling a
story
that the first step in getting a pair of
boots produced is a tag gets pronounced
so an order comes in that order gets
printed out and andy's all about
efficiency
and the orders would have the the human
being's name on it that ordered it so if
echo charles ordered a pair of boots it
would say echo charles size 11 bison
this soul whatever give and then
everyone knows what to make
and he just you know to save ink or
whatever took it out and and make that
tag a little bit smaller say oh we don't
need to know the person's name why is
that important and the and the workers
said hey what are you doing we want to
know who we're making this we want to
know who jim smith we want to know that
we're making jim smith's boots
and that shows you
what their mindset is right the mindset
is that they're personally connected
they they're they're personally engaged
in making the product quality product
they want to know who who by name who
it's going to
you know the thing is is after
like after
you know the whole national shutdown
last year and we pivoted and i'm sure
we'll talk about pivoting to making some
face coverings but then we came back to
the footwear plant we dealt with some
major issues getting back into
production
it just wasn't running smooth and it
almost like there was uh
at that point a lot of people home
they're collecting you know the
the uh additional unemployment
additional employment money
they didn't have to be at work whatever
so i said time out
and i talked to andy and i said we need
to get them more engaged i said so we're
gonna shut down production for a whole
day
they're gonna pick their leather the
team here and
they're gonna make boots for each other
they can make them for themselves or
they can make them for a loved one and i
want to see what happens
well guess what happened every single
boot off the line was the first quality
boot and so it was kind of a flank
i i gathered them all at the end of the
day they have huge smiles on their faces
and i said what'd you guys think about
that and they're like that was awesome
i said you made footwear for each other
they're like yeah and i said
and you injected soul into it because
you cared they're like yeah and i said
and that's what we need to do for every
customer and now every every name on
there and you know when andy stripped it
off like put that name back on if we're
gonna inject soul into this thing we
need to know there's a there's a real
human behind it so
yeah you know what you are making boots
for each other right yeah and now you're
gonna make boots for america exactly
in production production improved and uh
quality improved and
yeah man it was phenomenal little little
team building flank i guess you could
say yeah that's awesome what
prior to covid hitting though we we got
hit like
we made some missteps on mulch bars so a
little background is we want to make
mold bars right
protein bars good for you i have
probably ridiculously high standards of
what i want them to be and i just want
to eat a damn candy bar yeah you want to
eat a candy bar well and i also have
high standards that i want it to taste
like a candy bar but i don't want to use
any sugar i want to have a certain
amount of protein in it want it to be
natural so it's a really tough thing to
do
and we kept trying to crack this formula
and probably
probably the biggest mistake we made
i would say is we bought a bun we we
kind of settled on a bar we did that was
hella good as they say in california
this thing was hella good it kind of
tasted like a reese's peanut butter cup
um but it was bigger
and it was had no sugar in it and it was
covered in thick chocolate i mean it was
redonkulous man it was good good to go
so we thought okay this is it and but
the problem was it was it was really
difficult to make and a bunch of bar
producers around the country they
wouldn't do it couldn't do it can't do
it won't do it
couldn't stand behind it so of course
what did we do we'll just do it
ourselves 100 invest in the machinery
get it done and
there is there is a there being naive is
definitely a superpower but being
ignorant and arrogant is definitely not
that there's a balance that sometimes
the line gets crossed
you know we've been on such a solid run
the line did get crossed and when that
thing went off to shelf life testing it
didn't work
and basically if i tried to sum this up
we were doing a process called extruding
yeah which means you squeeze out this
tasty like the peanut butter cup part
that
middle part yeah you squeeze that out
through the machine and it kind of just
pops out the extruder yeah yeah well the
problem was when you do that you squeeze
out a lot of the the natural fluid
inside of it the oils the oils it gets
squeezed out and so when you put it on
the shelf for the shelf life test after
whatever two three months
which is how long it needs to taste good
for you he actually needs to taste
longer for that but as soon as we got to
two three months it was like hey this
doesn't taste the same this is dry wait
a second it doesn't work you're
refurbishing those old mills because it
turned into a brick yeah yeah it was not
it was not good so we uh
i just actually told joe on on friday
before camp i said hey man let's get
this equipment on pallets and get it
wrapped
and uh
make make way for some other thing so it
was a tuition payment that we learned
from and because of that
we we recruited
we hired and recruited a food scientist
that came in from
arizona
um another food scientist who serves for
quality it was kind of a point where
looking at the organizational structure
as we're growing
was like we've got to have the right
people in the right places if we're
going to start doing [ __ ] like this
um we've been we've been shotgunning it
for so long and just like just grinding
it out
that really was a defining moment in
how we need to start thinking we got
stores ready to buy this we got
i mean vitamin shop they're like when
are the bars coming when are they
they're ready to place a purchase order
for these things imagine if we had just
done it and sent it out and
all of it like molded it or something
yeah yeah well even if it didn't mold
even if it just tasted even if it just
tasted dry or just crumbled it would
have been bad
the latest version because we're still
on the oh we're still on it yeah
the latest version that i had was
freaking legit and it's weird because
it's like a bar but it tastes like
uh
a relatively
dense
brownie
it tastes like a
moist brownie when you say it it sounds
better it broke no i'm saying and then
it's coated with chocolate yeah it's
freaking nuts it's good it's really good
yeah
and we're ready to go but we've slowed
down to speed up yeah just making sure
we get it right this time
yeah because we got people that we
are waiting on that one yeah myself
included yeah
yeah yeah that one is freaking good
all right so we hit the malt bar it took
us a while we learned some lessons there
um a little too aggressive
a little too
a little too arrogant on what we what we
thought we could get away with and what
we thought we knew and you know what
that's we've also succeeded with that a
bunch you know you're going to take some
losses yeah you know you go out you take
risks a lot of risk we've taken a lot of
risks along the way
everyone's why you're going to get an l
up on the board
was a big l
oh man are we gonna sell that equipment
what are we gonna do with it oh he's
gonna yeah probably sell it
we'll probably sell it we're gonna have
to sell it um that's gonna be a
loss yeah pennies on the dollar
anyone need an extruder right there
the packaging machine was the big one oh
we got a beautiful packaging machine all
right so if anyone's looking for that
let us know we got something we got some
stuff actually we should just talk about
the other tuition payment then which
other one the uh
the the canned tuition payment
yeah well that was in the middle of
covid yes it was before we get there
before we get there
let's talk about when covet hit because
we made a we made a freaking legit pivot
pivot
uh i'll tell you my recollection
um
two months
before covet hit america yep
i had three or four friends
a couple seals
maybe like a seal
doctor medic
someone else
sent me you know text email whatever
saying like hey dude you should make
masks
and you and i had a very quick
discussion i said hey man we there's
this thing going on overseas and what i
was thinking is we'd ship them overseas
that was the conversation that i had
with my friends it was like all of them
are saying hey they're going to need
these masks and
you pulled up a couple examples of n95
masks because that was kind of what was
being asked for so now it was all right
well you you said to me hey we'd have to
like tool up for it we got to buy these
machinery we were already kind of
paranoid about buying more machinery
that we could freaking questionably have
to go sell later
and you just looked at it like hey man
this is probably a no-go it's going to
be an investment buy machinery to make
these masks and i said ah cool all right
roger you know no factor and then
and then kovid started well now you fast
forward a couple months and we could
check emails i think i was maybe two
months ahead of it you had it you i
thought you got a call from like a
friend of the department of defense or
something that happened a little later
okay so then as it started ramping up in
america well that was probably yeah
you're right that was probably one i got
a call from the do do a friend from the
dod a friend that's a doctor a friend
that's a seal medic overseas and like
someone else so there was there was
definitely a triangulation that i should
have paid attention to
um and i did you know and talked about
it but you know sometimes you just look
at somebody think that's a that's
probably not not the best move and
that's what you said you're like hey man
we'd have to buy this plastic it
probably was i think it might have been
called an extruder i was like no more
extruders we're not doing it man forget
about it
so we we said no
but then so covet then starts hitting
america and then i had another
conversation with you because now you
started hearing people start started
talking about masks right
you should wear anything cut up a
t-shirt put it around your face yeah so
and i forget the pattern that happened
here but i do remember i said bro we
just need to make something to put over
your face
and then
you were like okay
and then i this is when we were in
lockdown now we're in like in lockdown
yeah so i i actually had to get uh cable
news because i didn't have cable news
but i wanted to see what the hell was
going on
so then i'm watching freaking uh fouchy
and he's like uh don't wear masks they
don't help and then i'd
text you or call me like hey dude
they're saying masks aren't doing
anything to forget it and you're like
okay cool
and then the next week it was like five
days later might have been monday to
friday because it was friday
that i was like hey bro they're saying
you have to wear something over your
face let's go and you're like on it
and then you design them over that
weekend that was a friday yeah by monday
designed on friday had the team come in
move all the machines around and we
started cutting and sewing shut down all
the divisions we had we had sat down in
my office myself in in dawn our cfo
and talked about
what happens if
like things get crazy
what happens if things get crazy what
happens if
if supply chains shut down how does that
gonna affect what we're doing and the
last thing you know you want to do is
get caught in the chaos of supply chains
and
i remember we sat down and we actually
looked at our projections for the year
and we started cutting
we cut all the way up to 70
of our projections out
to and then we found a way to continue
to survive yeah survival survival and
then yeah because by the way now the
sudden every jiu jitsu school in america
is shut down exactly and we knew which
was crazy 52 of our business for origin
is
is martial arts his jiu jitsu
it's a crazy statistic 52
and we're like this is gonna it's gonna
shut down and
we're gonna lose
hardcore so we we found out that like it
was 70 percent we could afford to lose
we figured out how we could lean things
out
and ultimately that friday pivot we were
the first ones in america to make
face coverings really and it was cool
cool design we i mean i mean we made
what a quarter of a million maybe over a
quarter of a million of them the factory
came together and it was
honestly it was the most beautiful thing
we've done as a team
it was really inspiring it was like a
freaking beehive when you walked in that
place in the morning ripping out 10 000
a day yeah you were sending me texts
where you know at lunch time you'd be
like we're at 3970.
oh yeah
yeah it was i mean it was uh
it was it was crazy you know and and
i mean it it went it went fast it was
six seven days a week working long days
we had the fire departments
in in the hospital we we decided to
pivot and we took the collar foam from
the ghee like the whole collar
yeah we got we ordered bulk um
lamination paper we had we had five
laminators set up and you just put the
lamination paper in the laminators then
we took those and then we just stitched
a piece of ghee collar on them and put a
piece of underwear elastic pant on from
our tights and filling up boxes and
sending those to the hospital so they
had face face shields you know it was it
was phenomenal to be part of just that
what i felt like was almost a wartime
effort there was this
sense of
nobody knew what was gonna happen yeah
no i was gonna say in the early days
that you know now you can look at and be
like well mass snowmass
but at that time it was like uh
everybody's on the same page everybody's
on the same page you need to wear
something over your face or all you
catch this stuff right everyone's saying
that and in hospitals they didn't have
it and first responders didn't have it
no so we were donating thousands of
these things to first responders
donating stuff to hospitals
and and people were buying it as well
because now companies needed to keep
their employees coming in if they were
in business that was what did they call
the critical need or what was the
essential essential worker they needed
to supply mass to their people so they
started ordering it was freaking crazy i
had one guy he was on the fire
department
he drove up to the factory and he parked
outside
and we like transferred some face
coverings to him and he had he he was in
the back of his truck and he like had
the hatch open dude this was like black
plague this is why this is when people
it was black
he's got like this little smoke puffer
thing to figure out how much smoke goes
through it like to see if the virus can
get through i mean it was
it was wild
and i'll tell you what i've always been
into like post-apocalyptic movies
i was like i'm having i'm having so much
fun right now just doing this i mean
obviously that was short-lived it became
really uh annoying to not be doing what
we'd love to do you know and be stuck
and lockdown and all that [ __ ] but
um
but we got through it yeah and and so
this thing going from making jiu jitsu
because you
ended up shutting down
all lines all lines all lines just to
make
face shields face coverings that's what
we were doing face shields and face
coverings we shut down one line at a
time over the course of uh
maybe five to eight days i think
including the boot i remember you i
remember you and i'd be talking and
you'd be like bro
you'd be like what do you think how much
material should we use how much and how
many do you think we're gonna sell and
you know you and i are just literally
throwing our best guess and betting
hundreds of thousands of dollars worth
of material yeah on how long this is
gonna last because because it what
didn't take you know you fast forward
from black plague day whatever that was
when it just everyone thought
and then you fast forward a few weeks
and i remember saying hey man this mask
thing ain't it ain't gonna stick like
they're start there's other other
reports are coming out and again
at the time you're just trying to do the
best with best judgment that you can use
but it seemed to me like hey this is
gonna this is gonna fade and
i mean obviously the mask thing didn't
fade no but what happened was other
manufacturers sort of started getting in
the game and ordering stuff from
overseas and then they're mass producing
it and then it's like okay so now the
market was completely saturated and
flooded so we kind of owned the market
for
how many months
it was three months i think it was
longer than that
we were we were ripping
we went through every bit of fabric we
had warpwick our compression apparel we
went through all of our denim like we
went we didn't make any out of we
our ghee pants material our twill that's
right we made we we went through all of
all of our fabric and the crazy thing
was
it was kind of a blessing in disguise
too
in the background
[ __ ] started to fall apart in our supply
chain starting with our tannery in maine
where we were tanning all of our leather
for the boots it was it was a tasman
tannery and i remember
them calling me
like maybe four five six months in
saying i don't think we're gonna survive
and i'm i'm thinking holy holy [ __ ] like
this tannery the last tannery in the
state of maine that's been around for
100 years they don't think they're going
to survive i started to think about our
other supply chains
i ended up getting on the phone with
someone from the federal government
and he said to me there's three
tanneries in the united states of
america that can make the boots for
america's military
it's gonna kill us if this tannery shuts
down
and so he he was gonna
fund partially fund us purchasing this
tannery i got on the phone with norm
tasman the head of the tasman family i'm
talking to this guy down in texas about
how to keep this thing alive
ultimately it was
an elephant we just you know we we
didn't want to take down
and yeah well you and i were having
that's another like million dollars of
conversation you and i are having about
do we go do we do well you know we break
open the coffers what are we going to do
you want to roll and it's like
i think i said no i was just i think i
remember calling you big bro i
i don't think we should do this you went
to it oh yeah you went to it yep and you
called me on the way home and you're
like bro i just this is a this is this
is a
you didn't call it a lemon but you were
like this is a lot this is a lot
there's a lot that needs to be done
there's a lot of management and
leadership that would need to take place
you were basically saying you would have
to surrender other fronts that we're
trying to fight on
in order to make this happen yeah and it
was just a no-go and so because of that
i started getting a hold of all of our
suppliers and seeing where they were at
and everybody started having the same
story can't get labor can't make the
product no one's standing at looms no
one in the die houses
no one injecting souls for boots
and
it started to get pretty shady from that
perspective
so just managing
really managing that whole year from a
supply chain perspective
when to slow down on the face covering
thing how to pivot back up and that
whole time
we lost our denim weaver i don't
remember that
we couldn't weave denim anymore and we
had the
real quick i think where we got lucky
i got lucky because i was saying hey bro
they're not gonna make people wear a
mask much longer that ain't gonna happen
and so we started to taper
and when we started to taper
they kept making people wear masks but
we got lucky in that
so many other people now came on the
market and started making them and
bringing them in from overseas you know
however long it took them to go to china
and say hey we need these things and it
took them time to run the cycle bake
them and then ship them over here by the
time they actually showed up here we
were already in the down swing of mickey
mouse so we got lucky in the fact
perfectly because i was thinking it
didn't seem
it didn't seem possible that we that
america would still be wearing masks
after because it didn't take long for
people to say oh it's actually only ten
percent effective and seven and then you
had the people showing the you know the
videos with the like that smoke stuff
coming out and being like yeah this is
you know again
couldn't know the future but we i think
that was a stroke of luck the fact that
we because otherwise we would have been
sitting on you know however many
we were doing it week by week
i remember you're like what do you think
30 000 more 50 000 more yeah you're like
let's do a half a week more you know and
like it was that those kind of numbers
somebody uh somebody emailed us about
profiteering
somebody emailed me about profiteering
and
i sent him an email back and i said we
employ a hundred hard-working
blue-collar americans
when google called us and asked us for
forty thousand masks
and asked us how much how much it cost
how much is one fifteen bucks how much
is forty thousand fifteen bucks it's
because we need to keep a hundred hard
working americans working
and get out of this thing so that we can
get back into our supply chains and if
we had to fund those supply chains which
we did which we did we had the fun
finding a new denim manufacturer and
commit to massive amounts of
denim to weave denim you know and and
really secure the supply chain like we
we played it
i think it was i think by design we
played it well there was some we were
lucky within there but by design we
played it well i think it was just real
strategic planning keeping
everybody motivated to want to continue
working when they didn't have to
you know especially
especially in the city in the time it
was scary but we
we had such a good team it was just a
tremendous team i can't
you know say enough good things about
them for sticking it out when they
didn't have to yeah i mean the
government was giving away
money to people that were unemployed for
whatever reason and it wasn't the normal
unemployment there was additional
unemployment there was like covered
unemployment yeah and it was a it was a
substantial amount of money that that
people are getting paid
and i knew people out in california that
were that were
making a ton of money
for
you know
for for staying at home yeah and
more money than a lot of people could
work it could make make working a job
100 and that's a tough
market to compete with yep hey do you
want to make two thousand dollars a
month working 40 hours a week
uh doing doing a hard job
or do you want to make 2 000 of work a
week or sorry 2 000 a month doing
nothing yeah and a lot of people just
said doing nothing we'll take that
you know what i mean and
actually i mean they still they still
did receive but they didn't
they didn't rest on that you know what i
mean they
they were part of it i was i would do
like weekly motivational speeches and
[ __ ] like not not meant to be
motivational but like look at what you
people are doing just that was good too
like again in the bubonic plague phase
of
when
you know when when we started making the
face shields
that were going to hospitals that the
hospitals couldn't get that they thought
were absolutely critical at the time
otherwise everyone's going to catch
coven yeah yeah yeah and so that felt
really good you know and and i think
that was good for the team to know that
america was calling out for this
equipment this personal protection
equipment and origen was able to on a
weekend yeah
over a weekend
start delivering and that has to do with
the ability having this
having this capability of doing
everything
there
everything every design the material is
all sitting there the people with the
skills to make patterns the people the
skills to sew whatever needs to be sown
that's freaking legit vertical
integration inside the united states of
america yeah
no one else had it nope
all right
so
the tannery shuts down you're out
hunting for oh this was cool too
because now we need leather and i think
what we how do we talk about it we
talked people found out that we needed
leather i think they were listening to
your podcast it was the seidel family
yeah and
they called us and said heard you guys
need help
oh yeah we need help
and they said we can we can take care of
you so we sent them what we were using
for leather and we went back and forth
with iterations
as we were coming out of kind of the
mass making covet thing and trying to
get back into making footwear
we had a little bit left of supply
they ramped up for us they started they
started tanning to our spec
and they got us back on track they
sourced the bisons i don't think they
were doing bison at the time and that's
a big thing for us is vice american
lakota bison leather cause that bison
leather feels good buttery it is good
you want to make like a pillow out of it
when you get them right you want to make
a pillow you want to make like a
washcloth outfit you know you want it
you it's that freaking nice i just love
the historical nature of it man like uh
of the tatanka
it's freaking legit
so um so they just they just stepped
right up to the plate oh yeah stepped
right up hammered it out for us got it
done and got us back on track and
you know i think i think that
a lot of these
we're all in the same place is the thing
like all of the supply chain they're all
in the same place dealing with the lack
of people
you know every every all of our
suppliers everybody dealing with a lack
of people
and
those relationships because we've
built them for so long with our supply
chain
they're trusting they're going to get
paid so when we're when we're placing
these massive blanket purchase orders if
we didn't have that relationship of
trust between us that just wouldn't
happen so
you know
i guess good on us for building those
relationships over the years so that we
we survived and thrived ultimately and
salute to seidel reaching out like 100
percent i mean that's unbelievable that
that's because you know because of you
though that's so freaking cool though
you know it's like i was i was saying
the other day to somebody um
when when someone listens to the podcast
i have a relationship with someone if
they listen to podcast yeah because we
have the same inside jokes they know you
know they know some things they know
some little inside jokes we use the same
words you know we got stories to refer
back to that we experience together like
if you're just listening to echo and i
you're listening to me talk about
invading the beaches of normandy or
going on the baton death march we shared
that experience if you're listening
so we
have shared common
history together
if you're just listening to this we have
common history together
and that's what a relationship oh he's
talking to andy about andy stumpf
when you meet another seal that is
younger than you or older than you
you never served with him
that you were retired before they joined
or you
went in after they retired you still
know them and you still have a common
shared history that something that you
did together
you weren't together but you both went
through buds you both were a new guy in
a platoon you both went to jumped out of
an airplane you both went through hell
we have these common things so you're
immediately you have an actual
relationship with someone you've never
met before
so it's the same thing with the podcast
so when you get someone like the side l
family they're like yeah oh
oh jocko needs leather
oh okay cool like we know him yeah yeah
let's reach out i get it it's like
showing up to the submersion camp and
everybody's showing up for jiu jitsu
yeah yeah you know
a direct connection
uh hey where were we
how far along were we
in making boots when coveted
like we were pretty we embryonic yeah we
had we had decided just to buy this
facility which was a coca-cola plant
and
so that was in 2019 yep and we had just
started late 2019 it was late 2019 late
we had just started getting machinery
moved in and setting up and we weren't
even really producing i was going to say
that we hadn't really started producing
yet we had made boots yeah we knew we
could do it we had the skills we had the
technology but we weren't quite there
yet no no
and um
so then in the middle of covid we lose
the supply of the leather we get the new
supply of leather thanks to the seidel
crew yeah
and then it's we decided we're gonna
start making boots yeah and yes and we
start making them yeah
yep yep barely but yes
barely why uh it's just um
a lot of reasons out of practice number
one you know uh
there were some there were some uh
bad seeds i guess you could say also
there was there's some negative
there's some animosity there's some
negative attitudes
you know and
those came out when we when i've kind of
flanked the team with you're going to
make your selves or a family a loved one
a pair of boots
specifically i wanted to gauge
everybody's non-verbal reactions at the
end of the day
and
there was a couple of individuals that i
thought
would would get there or i questioned
would get there but i was hoping they
would i didn't think they would and
engaging their their nonverbals i was
like got it they're not coming
not coming my way so
um
so maybe this so they weren't the right
people for yeah
it's amazing like you could have a team
of
15 unless you had a team of 15 people
making 50 pairs of boots a day you'd
think that if you lose three
then you'd lose the same percentage in
production what happens is you actually
gain
so it goes you drop to 12 and now you're
making 55 pairs there's just there's a
when when when cover and move is part of
your culture which it is for us you know
cover and move and you want to cover and
move for people you like
you know your your app to move quicker
and to be more responsive and to have
better peripheral vision and to see
where you can inject yourself to improve
the process and you give a [ __ ] and you
inject your soul into it and i think
i think we had lost some of that you
know during covid you know the factory
turned into a machine
it did
you know for better for worse it
literally turned into a machine when you
walked in there was like a beehive
buzzing
and we were just cranking six seven days
a week ten hours a day just burning
through
through thread and fabric and there
there there was there was motivation but
there wasn't a lot of culture building
over those three or four months it was
just had heads down heads down man and
you know what you got to do that [ __ ]
sometimes you got to do that [ __ ] and 99
of the factory
came out of it adjusted and it was
wonderful
but um
but there was a few folks that just uh
just didn't make it and um so once once
we took care of that everything came
came around so you were you you gave a
quote the other day or you asked a
question
or you made the statement about how much
it cost to make the first pair of origin
boots
half a million bucks
and then what's funny is someone was
like someone said uh
well those must have been some awesome
boots and i was kind of like not really
like the first pair of boots that i got
were like
i was like send me you know change these
things this sucked tongue fell out
freaking souls coming up like you know
it was wasn't that bad but it was
definitely even to get the first
prototype boot
took
a lot yeah but yeah putting a half a
million dollars of money
of our money yeah into that just buying
equipment and bro you want to talk about
you want to talk about uh freaking trust
cause i was sketch on boots yeah yeah
man from the word go i was sketch on
boots because they seem very difficult
they look hard hard to make to me right
i look at a pair of boots and i think
man that seems like that seems like it's
gonna be a problem you know
like
you know it's hard for me to understand
how like a piece of thread goes through
that big piece of leather and how's that
going to work and who's doing that and
it just seems
seems like more challenging and i and i
brought this to your attention yeah you
did i said bro look man it's hard to
make geese like
um
this doesn't seem like a smart idea and
the other thing that scares me about it
is first of all they're they're really
expensive yeah
and second
you know if you make t-shirts
you got to make
small medium large extra large right
if you make boots you got to make size 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14. by the way you
know one pair of
one brand i wear an 11 another brand i
wear a 10 another brand i wear 13 so now
you got people that are pissed off
because it's not the right size it just
seemed to me i was paranoid man i was
definitely paranoid and and you like
you're like no man boots are easier than
geese you said to me i was like okay and
i i believed you you know easier than
weaving easier than weaving
and i said okay
and that was a high level trust bro you
might as well have like been playing
russian roulette with my head
because that's how i felt about it and
then we're spending a half a million
dollars on freaking equipment and i'm
like
yup cool sounds great man i'm holding my
breath
and then you sent me the first pair that
was like maybe
uh version four or something version
three and i could already go oh
wait something there oh yeah this is
gonna be good yeah so
that was a high level of trust i
appreciate that i'm glad i didn't screw
up on the mock bars before that
[Laughter]
and then what's crazy is while all this
is going on
well
we just we were running out of room
overall because now
because now we're having to buy
because now jocko fuel is going berserk
right well everybody's got to understand
we're self-funded
so we've never taken on capital like
we've always self-funded if we make a
profit you know a large chunk of that
gets injected back into what we're doing
and in 2017 at the grand opening
i don't know what do we have for how
many employees do we have 12 12 12
employees yeah when you and i shook
hands we had eight okay and and so then
we decided we're going to start joggle
fuel so everyone's sewing in the factory
and all the pallets of jackal fuel are
in between the sewing machines
like that was our warehouse was this
factory floor was our warehouse too you
know just
winning at all costs you know whatever
needs to whatever needs to happen
so
and jocko publishing books are in there
i know it was i forgot about that taco
publishing mikey and the dragon stacked
up in there oh man
so um
i forgot about that yeah you know when
you think about blitz scaling to we have
210 employees
you know over 2020 we hired another 40
employees
you know and so we're dealing with a
lack of infrastructure uh that you know
really a decaying infrastructure the
fact that there is only
i don't know one or two buildings left
in our community you know within a half
a mile radius that actually could hold
our growth
and
we did the boot plant
we invested in that coronavirus hit
we had invested another facility for
nutrition oh yeah i forgot to mention
about the equipment we want a building
yeah so we're just getting crazy we're
getting crazy and we're we're self well
when i say self funding i mean you know
we're we're working with banks working
the banks to make all this [ __ ] happen
because we can see it now
i'm not sure if that's being naive as a
superpower or just being naive but
i i believe in our vision you believe in
our vision and we know we've got
something special
you know you know how i know that
because we have people moving from all
over america to work for us i'm talking
colorado
arizona nevada
georgia there was i said arizona yeah
massachusetts connecticut i'm everywhere
and
when
when everyone's saying the same thing
like i want to be part of this i can see
what you guys are doing it's special i
get it like and it's resonating with
them we just got to tell more people so
we invest in in that's part of business
i mean it's the
i learned a lot about organizational
structure and you know i've learned way
more than i ever thought i would know
about running a a business of this size
this magnitude five facilities 210
employees
i mean it's it's a lot
and
i never like believed in titles like
everybody just do what needs to be done
like literally we got done eating steaks
last night and i was in the kitchen with
the deck we were washing the dick we
washed all the dishes all the forks like
just do it do it needs to be done like
get [ __ ] done
but i do understand
now because of the situation
how you have to really detach to look at
to look at
i don't i hate to use the word
battlefield because it's not a
battlefield but to look at the
organization
and do you have the right players in the
right positions
are you missing people and sometimes
just letting the fire burn
and what i mean by that
actually was saying this to me pete
you got to just let the fire burn for
some of these things you can't solve all
the problems all the time now you don't
want to get it out of control you don't
want to become a blaze i said but if you
can't solve this part of your company
like the issues we're dealing with let's
say in finance we had a cfo but we
really need four people in that
department
because don's work you know 100 hours a
week
he's like just you got to let the fire
burn and if it's not done perfectly and
if it's not closed the corners aren't
closed on time that's okay let the fire
burn media same thing
and focus on the on the things that
really have a massive impact and then
get the people to solve the problems
i really really learned that lesson this
year yeah um prioritize and execute yep
and that's a huge one and then
decentralized command
and what decentralized command
ultimately the power that it gives you
in you when you're in a leadership
position is you have the ability to look
up and out instead of down and in so
instead of looking down and in at your
team instead of looking down and in and
what the schedule is for today and who's
on the line and who's not and who's sick
and who's not instead of looking down at
in at that which
which takes away your your overall
vision of what's happening on the
battlefield you have to be looking up
and out and so yeah you you definitely
got that um and and look you're not
gonna solve every problem and sometimes
you gotta be like oh yeah yeah that's
gonna suck um okay got it we accept that
suck fat factor on that thing because we
can now focus on our efforts on
something that's gonna that would suck
way worse and be much worse for
everything that's going on here
but
we
you again you and i have some
conversations that are
million dollar conversations
we're making decisions and what's funny
to me is they're still like three minute
conversations
but but like because we bought a few
buildings since it's been
so since 20 since 2019 yeah we've bought
what three more four more buildings yeah
three going on four yeah with a new
edition of north carolina yeah actually
we're not buying a building buying the
business yeah so um
but these are big investments
and
and the the jocko fuel warehouse as as
everything was just overflowing we
needed
we needed to go big yeah we needed to go
big and also need to go big on our
supply chain
um you know having enough stuff in stock
that when people order we can fulfill it
well the thing is is
as we were dealing in i remember really
sitting down
on the phone with you with joe and brian
our chief revenue officer and chief
product officer
sitting down and saying hey listen guys
learn something during this with with
apparel and footwear
where our supply chains are local let's
say on the east coast
i think
shit's gonna happen on the nutritional
side
let's lock down everything we can the
whole supply of monk fruit
and we ended up locking down aluminum
too
and that was kind of the big one that
was that was a lucky one that was lucky
i mean i didn't think like
people
i didn't think we were gonna be affected
by people not at bars drinking off a tap
and because normal you know people are
going to the store and buying 12 packs
of beer aluminum cans well it's a it's
aluminum doesn't matter what the can is
it matters at the there's an aluminum
shortage
so like securing the supply chains of
the raw ingredients and the cans allowed
us to really eat market share at the
same time and i think to what you're
saying is
having
having being able to look up and out
versus get stuck in the trenches of just
survival it really allowed us to to
thrive and actually it taught me how to
be a ceo for the first time ever so i
was like ceo yeah that's just a [ __ ]
title that i don't want but
i actually get it because
some of the
the decisions that
ultimately sometimes i just have to make
they are
they're multi-million dollar decisions
but they could make or break us you know
and i'm i i don't want to screw up man
i don't want to screw up how good
how good did it feel to take a quarter
million of those precious cans of
product no and throw them away
because that's exactly what happened
this is another tuition payment
yeah that was a tough not to swallow so
250 000 cans 250 000 cans we have the
destroyer this was what when was that
was that
uh
2020 yeah it was like three quarters of
the way three quarters away to 2020. so
so at that time that was a big chunk of
a big chunk for us big chunks it's a big
chunk now but it's a much less
substantial it's been another it's been
a year since then but at that time it
was a lot yeah and it was especially a
lot because aluminum was short it was
hard to get the stuff run on the lines
so 250 000 cans was substantial yes we
and we what had happened was um we had
leaked some of the cans of this
250 000 cans
were had been sealed wrong
and it was like one in six that were
actually leaking yep and so luckily we
caught it
and then what do we do we consulted
legal oh yep here's what you do oh what
what do you do you destroy them all
bro
i i yeah i couldn't even watch it so a
couple tuition payments yep the funny
thing about that was maine thai
who
what so we're shipping uh this is this
is main thai yeah maine tai who's a part
of the media department yep does he run
the media department he's a media
department he's a media manager he's
okay so the media manager main tai
he uh when we when we had to destroy 250
cans of go of which one out of six was
actually bad yeah he would he was he
didn't care
he started making runs with his jeep as
many he said he's got a lifetime supply
right now of jocko discipline go at his
house he's got the power palette upon
palette so there's an amazon seller
there's an amazon seller who's creeping
up on us
needs to get checked out
he loaded up though
yeah yeah he did he was i was laughing
my ass off when he was done he sent you
a video oh he told you no he just was
telling me about it it's like you gotta
be kidding me i went down there with my
jeep about ten times
his uh his grandparents are in the game
his grandmother drinks to go she's
always tagging like fire fire america
strong strong strong
we said are we sponsoring her now
yeah yeah she's uh she's like 80's we're
sponsoring her she's the she's the
freaking jocko yeah
athlete
um
all those are hard
but there was there were other there's a
couple other events that happen
in the past couple years that have been
freaking really hard um
yeah i mean losing people losing people
yeah
yeah we lost to two
two really good ones um
we we had this young kid moe uh
wasn't about 19 years old
awesome kid just started jiu jitsu
this kid's life was sports
basketball player
in high school just a tremendous athlete
and
first time on the mats i was like this
kid is gonna be special and he had just
gotten into it
um
dealing with dealing with depression
and ended up taking his own life
during uh
during the whole pandemic and uh just a
terrible
terrible loss that really
stunned
you know the factory and
his team downstairs um in the bunker but
i i i think like man if he if
i hate to say like
like put this on jiu jitsu but
man if he had started like a little bit
earlier and gotten back into that team
type of atmosphere
i know what it could have done for him
like i know what jiu jitsu has done for
people in his situation
you know and uh
i actually should have pushed harder
to like get him to training more you
know like it just i didn't
um
really shitty situation we lost uh
him and then
we also lost lenny so
lenny
was uh
he's the man he's the guy that got us
going man when it came to weaving he did
everything
just give us a little background on on
how you or how you found or how you [ __ ]
you kind of found lenny yeah um there
was a need
kind of a desperate need a desperate
need to weave to weave fabric because
there wasn't any fabric in america that
we could make geese with ultimately and
if you want the fabric either imported
from china or pakistan and that wasn't
an option
so i just i called around looking for
knowledge and
we
just asking everybody who do you know
who's done this before driving around
trying to find people i just i literally
like just chasing information
you know reconnaissance you know and we
discovered this guy and i told him what
we wanted to do we we had this old loom
and
man he said he'd help us refurbish it
i didn't know what we were getting into
again naive when it came to weaving
fabric and this is so did you already
have
did you already have the loom at this
point they they came about at the same
time
found the loom and then found lenny
where did you talk to him for the first
time
at the
at the bates mill we stood there and
looked at that friggin loom together so
as you were going to get the loom he
went with you yep through the through
the chain of people that were involved
in the project
he came into it he was working with a
museum to help them get the museum right
and make sure the looms were right for
this museum
and
he came in and we looked at this loom
and he straight up was like i can make
that work
and just those i can make that work
five words
i was like let's do it
you know just blind faith
so lenny
i mean that guy
really
he's one of the main reasons for our
success and
and our ability to do what we do because
when i asked lenny and you've heard me
say this before how many people know
what you knew and he's like a whole
bunch like how many like how many new
england he's like well at least five
there's at least five
five people
you know and he invested all of his
knowledge into
obviously myself and john and this young
kid cam who knows more than john and i
put together times 10. so this young cam
who's in his early 20s
um lenny spent hours upon hours upon
hours with him
teaching him over a three-year period
and
he passed um
and it
sucks
bad
you know like i
man
first time i broke down a long time like
losing him he
he meant the world to the company and to
the people of origin and just was such a
tremendous
tremendous uh
asset so
we did start a
like a scholarship program in his name
so that was pretty awesome but
yeah so now the the thing is on us it's
all on us there's no more calling lenny
i uh
i have a
voicemail actually
i kept on my phone
i'm not i'm never going to delete it you
know it's like the last the last
voicemail he left me
i listen to it every once in a while
actually
so
yeah
he's the man
and his wife thea she still still calls
and stops by and she's just
heartbroken um
i'll tell you what
when i talk about like the old-timers
the last ones left
he was the last one
it was ones
that was plural
he's the last one he's he was the last
one in maine
there ain't nobody else in maine that
has his
that has his knowledge
well the the
awesome thing is is that
if you wouldn't have done what you did
that
never would have been captured
no there'd be no cam there'd be it just
would it just wouldn't happen god that
the business the industry would be dead
forever
like when they say oh it's impossible to
bring back
it would have been
it would have been virtually impossible
to take back so much so that
there's a company in america that weaves
and weaves denim and they work for some
brands
and they flew up to maine recently
and
i'm not going to say what the brands are
but they're well known brands
international well-known brands
and there's a guy here who's been in the
industry for you know 30 years 40 years
new york city
you know big denim guy
ran
ran programs
for the biggest denim brands
and
i said man why are you in maine
like why are you here and he's he's like
can i film your operation i'm like yeah
sure have at it film it like i don't i
don't care it's like how'd you figure
out how to do all this i said we just
figured it out we just choose common
sense he's like yeah but how did you
like learn how did you where'd you get
the operators i said we
hired them without any skill and we
trained them and we taught them about
our culture and what we're all about and
they bought in
and they became better at it because
they care
and he just couldn't believe it he
couldn't believe what's happening
and he said
you're the only ones that can do this
i said what are you talking about
he's like you're
outside of california this company
is the only ones that can
make jeans
i said what about all the brands you
work with the big ones
he said i've asked them all the same
question
why don't you guys set up your own
manufacturing and they all have the same
answer
because we don't have the knowledge
anymore
that was 20 years ago 25 years ago we
don't know how to do it and so they're
soliciting us
to set up cut and sew
so that
these brands big brands
can
make jeans in america and i can tell you
one of those brands is levi's because
levi's called us to ask if we would make
jeans for them
and um of course
you know we said no
because we're savages
because we rip people's faces off
but uh you know
lenny lenny was was the last one and the
knowledge is really where
there's a vessel of knowledge is origin
it's one of our biggest assets is just
the sheer knowledge
so it's a it's a beautiful thing to be
part of
yeah and that that's one of those
stories right there um i remember you're
sending me a text like
you just got an email from levi's i'm
like okay
that's this should be an interesting
call yeah but it's another one of those
things where the tactical short term
move
that can be very beneficial in the
immediate
but if you look at it over the long term
you realize that it's not aligned with
what it is we're trying to do and we ran
in the same thing you know we had a we
had
some
very nice offers presented to us in the
past
year really maybe a year and a half
um
that i think
i actually think
99.9 of the people in the world would
have have taken these offers on board
and and executed
um you know huge amounts of money
and
a lot of security
but
what you sell for that security and what
you sell for that money is the dream and
the vision
and
you know you you and i we we had some
good conversations about it
but
i think a lot of times we had
conversations
that we were talking
we were discussing
our mouths were moving
but our hearts were already we already
knew what the answer was
and it was almost like hey man what what
do you think like well
i mean we could yeah we could well it'd
be nice that'd be nice
um it's it's a risk that's a risk we
could have we we'd have all those
conversations and in the end it would
just each time it's been
it's a sacrifice
of the vision it's us it's going away
from the ultimate goal it's
giving up
what it's giving up control
when there is
and you give up
control with people that might not be
going where we're going
and if if they're in a different place
and all of a sudden someone else is in
control or you got to deal with someone
i've had this conversation plenty of
times i even with certain investors i've
said listen
pete and i make decisions in three
minutes
three minutes
three texts
we figure out what we're going to do
this
that is what that's one of the major
reasons why i'm hesitant to do anything
because i'm going to have to deal with
you people
and you might you look you seem like
nice people i get it
but you have
what you have a direction that you want
to go in
and
we
i'm not sure what that direction is i'm
not sure where you want to go i know for
a fact where pete and i want to go
and so you start throwing variables in
there
and then on top of that
you know you start trying to put a price
on those variables
and and it becomes
well we haven't done it big prices too
yeah big the thing is it's almost like
inevitable when you think about where we
need to go and how to get there
you know yeah at some point we will have
we will likely have to take some
outside capital on board
um every it seems like every day every
week that we don't
we are in an even better position where
maybe we can
muddle through it a little bit further
and then you look at me like we're doing
all right
okay we'll get up he's good can you
breath hold another three months here
yeah i can hold my breath yeah can you
yeah i can yeah you're gonna be good
with it yeah i'm okay man yeah yeah you
can okay we're good you're good yeah and
we look we've done that for the last
year and a half it's been a lot of that
every
almost every week
though we we overcome an obstacle we
make a move that turns out good we've
taken some hits too but that just gives
it gives us so much more security to
move forward with just us
i feel like the uh
the wormhole is closing you know like
we've been in this wormhole and you can
see the light in it and it's like this
and we're going and we're moving towards
it we're moving towards it and we're
picking up speed
and we've got to get through the
wormhole before shots
you know and
it's a it's a difficult place to be you
know
in into to read
because
doing what we do is
is unique in it it makes us feel alive
and we're completely aligned and working
on the same frequency
and having fun
but we're building something that's
going to transcend us at the same time
you know what i mean it's like
holy [ __ ] getting to the next level is
the big deal bro
what what were we on the inc 500 in 2020
like 2020 last year for last year
the year before last yeah we were 364
on the inc 500 and then this year and
for 2020
we finished 215.
what did you think about rush that would
you think about for
a company that did what we did it just
shows the strength of our people and our
culture and our vision to finish
as a 215th fastest growing business in
america that's crazy from the freaking
woods of nowhere maine
[Laughter]
i mean
and
literally doing what we're saying we're
going to do yes
and an example that that i'm thinking of
right now is we keep saying we're
bringing manufacturing back to america
oh what does that really mean i'll tell
you what it means a trip to the
dominican republic
to buy equipment and literally ship it
back to america yeah talk to me about
that
well andy andy found this this equipment
our ceo over there at the footwear
division and he's like this is what we
need to make safety tow boots and he's
gone all in you walk into his office
it's all books on making footwear he
knows how to make shoes he knows how to
make patterns i mean this is a guy who
came from setting up plants for toyota
now working on footwear
and he was super nervous
he's like here's the list of stuff we
need to bid on here's what i think we're
gonna need it's coming out of a
timberland factory timberland boot
factory and the dominican that's
shutting down
and
i was like cool man let's get whatever
we need
he was just super nervous about it so we
sat in the conference room and we bid
real time yeah
we
you're posting that stuff on freaking
instagram yeah
hey bro
did you say hey bro do you think you
should be posting on instagram someone's
gonna bid against you i know i was
worried i'm like dude what are you doing
like you're showing everybody their
stuff for sale hold off give me a 20
minute interval wait till the freaking
bidding closes
come on bro let's be strategic we uh we
did we got it we secured the stuff we we
really needed two container fulls of
machine
and we sent we sent joe my father-in-law
down there
with uh with andy and nicole and
you know we
thank god nicole's fiance is from the
dominican
so he's like packing heat here he knows
everybody who he has to pay off because
this is no small feat to get there and
to get in like safely where we needed to
go to this factory this is during covid
was it
i mean yes it was i mean of course it
was it was
so uh they get over there and you got
this you got joe from the woods of me i
mean the biggest redneck on the planet
you know what i mean
i know what you mean
strutting through the streets you know
in his uh
in his in his
jean shorts
that the girls made them at the factory
oh man
and uh and they they did it they they
paid off everybody they needed to pay
off like
it was a mission i mean a straight-up
mission so we pulled that back and all
the machinery we had a technician come
and go through everything and get it all
running and it is beautiful the
machinery looked beautiful it's
incredible i mean some of the shit's
like a year old
and what that was all that was most of
that was geared towards making
safety
boots because we've had a huge demand
signal for safety
and it's coming this fall safety tow
boots uh echelon front
the our work with construction companies
is so massive yep there's because the
the correlations between
like
running a seal platoon and running uh
running a military unit and running um a
construction site they're really really
similar yeah and it's a real
level of where
the explanations just make so much sense
to them we massive and and they all are
in the game they're all in the game
they're like
when the work pants come out that's
gonna get buck wild yeah you know when
the work pants come out
and the reason i say this because i have
a pair and i know
that and i work construction as a kid
and those things are going to get the
the perfect pants for work yeah they
really are
they're they're like the pants you want
in a post-apocalyptic environment
that shit's going to last forever
totally over built totally overbuilt
like over-engineering
over-engineered like you read about yeah
but the point is of the reason i'm
bringing that up is
this this talk
about bringing manufacturing back
there's no better example of that than
going to a foreign country getting the
equipment and bringing it literally back
to here so we can build yep that's
freaking legit
uh
do you when did you get covered i got
covered before you right yeah i got it
in uh december and echo got it you and i
got it together we had the joint coved
you and i were just we were kind of
skated through it a little bit we
definitely skated through fine with it
yeah you lost your smell
i didn't lose anything i had a couple
workouts that were cut weak
a negative
i don't know mine i forget mine's a
positive
is that a thing yeah they said it they
said like a positive you were down hard
you were down hard oh yeah i mean i made
it look good on instagram okay this is
no factor and i'd put my phone down and
just boom right back right back it was
weird too because maine and especially
farmington you guys didn't get
no we didn't get hit no we locked it
down pretty good
we didn't get hit like the rest of the
country yeah
so
i mean it it you know it was an
experience so how many people total at
origin got coveted um
eight
that's unbelievable how did you not
spread it
so
lots of
conversations with the whole team hey
listen when you leave your house in the
morning
make sure you're making you know if you
can make one stop
and on that stop make sure you're
getting the things you need for the day
and
then go straight home after we ask
everybody to have basically say low
impact have super low impact
um we just you know
we made sure everybody was aligned to
follow kind of
those guidelines so you got covered
though all right yeah i did so you got
covered what i'm saying is
how did you not go into the factory for
two three days shake hands hey let me
get on that machine hey look what do you
think of this you're looking over the
shoulder
it was christmas new year's day got it
so you got lucky got lucky did you how
long did it take you before you knew you
had it
i knew immediately oh miss rona yeah i
knew immediately i uh you could just
feel you felt sick oh yeah i felt it i
was like did you wouldn't would you
would you what are you echo did you did
you i think i told you i yeah so
that was the worst the worst thing for
me was i had to call everybody i had to
call everybody i knew that i had been in
contact with and say hey
hey
like this is the hey i'm i was and i was
i guess i was texting people because it
seemed more efficient yeah um and the
worst was tulsi
because tulsi came to visit us
we would have recorded a podcast but uh
she like last minute thing and she only
had a little bit of time so she's like
hey just want to come by and say hi
we're like cool come on by and so you
came in i think we trained and then we
trained and then she came in
and she hung out but i will say she wore
two masks
the whole time and and at this point
ekko and i we
we were in our own whatever cove bubble
we said you gave echo
we went on a trip we went up to northern
california we met with cowboy and we met
with we met with tilt until we did it
and that was the hardest thing about
this and and look we don't know where we
got it whether cowboy gave it to us but
cowboy cowboy was a vietnam vietnamese
sog guy sog operator just a total badass
guy he dude
you know you watch that podcast he's
like pulling up his shirt showing oh i
got stabbed here got shot here got blown
up over here
and then all of a sudden he gets covered
and he was in the hospital stuff it was
bad yeah um and by the way the troopers
that i posted about it because it it hit
his whole family and like people just
donated a ton of money and really helped
him out man so thank everybody for doing
that
but wherever we got it because we'd
flown up there we stayed in a hotel we
get done with that and he had had some
family event or whatever i don't know
anyways we all end up getting covered
and then tulsi came and what made it
hard about what i felt bad about tulsi
because tulsi went from being with us to
flying out to
damn dc and they were
they were paranoid level 12 out there
and so she's like yeah if
i've been exposed she goes i have to
quarantine for 12 days i was like what
she's like just for being exposed to us
i feel horrible so sorry so she surfed
for 12 days no i think no she was in dc
so she couldn't go home and hawaii was
real strict too so it was but but you
know what she ended up getting like two
back-to-back tests and she was negative
negative and so ended up being all right
which was cool
uh what about like your own
what about so we we kind of talked about
the business
kovid was kind of
kind of like a little bit rough on pete
roberts
as a human well i did i went down for a
couple of weeks my whole i gave it to my
whole family and my father-in-law they
were pissed no one in my family got it
really and we didn't i you know i didn't
stay with did you quarantine yourself or
anything i
after i when i had it i had to yeah i
stayed in i stayed at in my property did
you stay away from your family though
well i didn't know i had it and then i
had i must have gotten a pretty massive
viral dose and so then i gave it to my
my mother-in-law my father-in-law my son
my daughter my son's best friend my wife
his freaking parents xander you're a
freak
i they sent him up to the woods of maine
to a cabin for two weeks his parents
sent him up by himself there's like one
store up up there that he would walk to
and get his goods or whatever maybe he
had him delivered i don't know bro no
one in my family got it that's great and
i didn't we and we didn't i mean my
family because we we're like okay well i
got it so we all go we're just stuck
together we're all gonna get it and no
one got it weird that's weird i mean i
was even before i knew i had it which i
obviously had it i was like you know my
wife and i are
you know like i blame it on chips chips
chips chips chips you eat what do you
mean i eat chips oh potato chips to
everybody else
potato chips cape cod kettle stuff oh
potato chips
i played giving kovid to everybody on
cape cod chips
but my mother-in-law was super pissed
she was super pissed at me
and i'm like you're welcome
after she you know it was fine i was
like you're welcome
she didn't like that either
what about what about your uh training
during miss rona yeah i mean i i i was
shut down for two weeks i was done and
then when i got back into working out or
trying to work out it was like literally
five minutes i was like
do you still feel like miss rona in your
in your lungs so
i
honestly there's some cognitive things
going on
for me there's like beyond just your
normal yeah yeah limited capacity
i mean it's pretty limited as it is
you know what i'm saying like i'd you
know no there's so there's a little bit
of [ __ ] going on but uh all good i feel
like
i mean i feel super healthy now you know
even though i put on 40 freaking pounds
you put on 40 pounds 40 man wait i found
it wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
freaking
it's a post-apocalyptic kind of
environment
you know
you're just going daily like this could
be it man
i'm thinking survival you know you got
that extra layer on you you know you
gotta fast for a week or two the food
the food supply is dwindling guess what
you're ready guys living
[Music]
unless you decide to take me out and
carve it away you put on 40 pounds
before or after during nah during cove i
put i put on 40 pounds during cove wait
when you had cochlear implants
did you lose weight when you had covet
yeah i i dropped like 10 pounds okay
yeah and that was because you were
couldn't eat that was because yeah yeah
you were sweating you were sick yeah
sweating sick and and then couldn't
taste anything so the only thing that
actually felt good in my mouth is that
old school campbell's chicken noodle
soup
so you're losing weight
and all right so um that's happening
with covered and then oh we had a bunch
of other crazy like awesome stuff going
on because we
that's another thing timing-wise we went
into vitamin shop yeah the entire jocko
fuel line goes into vitamin shop it
explodes
and goes berserk out of the gate and
then covet hits yep and all of a sudden
that's like goes on a little bit of a of
uh you know hesitation there because
people it shut down you know uh it
wasn't whatever what's the word again
critical mass critical essentials
was vitamin shop essential
they were we actually we actually the
vitamin shop we exploded in
because people
they were buying like
when you went into the stores like my
wife was telling me she's like
i'm going shopping this is like as
shit's coming across and you're wearing
the face coverings and everyone's got
masks on so she's going to the store and
she's like bubonic place i just needed
some essentials i needed some bread and
you know some tuna fish whatever she's
coming now they're ready to survive for
four years she's like pete she's like
i'm going down the aisle and i look and
there's brown bread and there's only one
left i've never bought brown bread in my
life she's like i had to put it in the
shopping cart because there's only one
left and that's the kind of like the
kind of chaos that yeah that went on and
then folks started going to gncs and
vitamin shops and anywhere else you
could get protein yeah
and supplements so it reminds me like a
little bit of hesitation and then it was
like
yeah oh yeah so that ended up being
awesome yeah it was good for business
and then same thing with going into wawa
which is the if you don't know what was
it's a massive uh convenience chain on
the east coast and we rolled into wawa
we rolled into wawa on a three month
test so if you don't know anything about
this kind of thing so
it's convenient stores
they're like the real estate
right they're like the real estate where
you you get to sell stuff yeah if you're
lucky they own it and they only want to
sell stuff that's going to sell so they
don't just you can't just walk into a
convenience store like oh i want to sell
my you know my my drink here they go we
don't care we don't want your drink get
out of here
because they want stuff that's going to
sell they want there to be a demand for
it and so
we
got we we had some relationships
luckily like everything's relationship
based joe moss had some relationships
and
so we they gave us a three-month test to
see how we do florida in florida
and um i think it was three weeks three
weeks into it
they called and said chain watch chain
wide because everyone all that are
listening this right now
went out and got crazy yes
and matter of fact it got to a point
where they asked me
to stop saying
go clear this because i was like hey if
you go to wawa clear the shelves and
people were like okay cool people are
posting videos of them just clearing
shelves into coolers from wawa freaking
awesome
so that was super helpful and awesome
that you all went out and did that and
so in three weeks they called us and
said can you can we get enough supply to
go chain wide
in now and we were like okay yeah so
that was and that's a that's um
an iconic
conversation
it's an iconic convenience store and
it's a benchmark it's a benchmark for
all convenience stores and we had to you
know we had to go crush a few wawa
hoagies oh yeah we got some hoagies on
but but that's opened up the doors now
there's
now there's uh we'll we should be
spreading to
many other convenience stores i don't
want to name them right now but they're
all over the country uh the one the
probably the hardest one to get into
as far as geographically when this is a
bummer is california california has some
convenience stores that we're we're just
we're not
we we're we're not in california the way
we want to be we'll find the right
partner but it's just it's a little bit
tricky of a of an atmosphere out there
which is weird too because california
like basically is convenience stores
like there's convenience stores
everywhere there's people that just
that's where they shop is convenience
stores you know like that's where
they're that's where it's happening
you know and so we'll but we're working
that that issue um to get to a point
where
where it starts to go forward
else
that's a pretty good year man
yeah you know when you think
and talking through this
holy [ __ ]
all this thing all this has happened at
the same time oh by the way we bought a
uh a business
a factory in north carolina in north
carolina by the way yeah we just closed
on that yep yep so all the papers are
signed so that's a massive amount of
capability that we're gonna have to so
even better and and north carolina
it's similar in many ways to what we
have up in maine what we have up in new
england where
this used to be the dominant
industry up here and it just faded away
and north carolina is similar
in many ways
and they have they also have they also
have parts of the industry down there
that are central in that area that
aren't central up here yes and so
that'll be a huge boost to what we're
able to do as well yeah when it comes to
like our heavy hoodies you know we have
the new heavy hoodies
joggers t-shirts
grappling shorts vice shorts board
shorts
knit products like all the all the new
stuff we're doing as we focus on
building origin and bringing bringing it
to the masses
blitz scaling
this it's just going to be phenomenal to
have this other facility so it's another
big
you know big step you know risk reward
you know and i think we we both buy into
that 100 i don't think that's like boots
i think it's
yeah i think that that big of a risk but
it's still uh
it's still crazy to
say we're gonna drive the same culture
we drive in maine and north carolina
you know and think through
having the right people in place and
processes and making sure that
you get enough face time there and get
them bought into what we're doing
um
from an extreme ownership perspective
you know and it's going to take time to
make all that happen yeah
one thing that is beautiful
about
the culture and them
you know them
this isn't us having to impose a
new culture
this isn't us having to say hey here's
what you think is important and here's
what we think is more you need to think
what like we think
because what we're doing
it just resonates
it's in
look guess what they do for a living
they sew stuff they make stuff they want
to make stuff in america just like we're
not trying to sell them something else
they're already on board
and so it's more like a unification yeah
and it's an opportunity
for them to have you know to do
more and better and bigger and the
people that are there right now to have
more opportunities and more job
stability and and earn more and make
more and do more like that's what
you don't have to convince somebody
you don't have to convince somebody of
that you know what the best part is the
place wasn't for sale
yeah was it for sale yep you know but
being able to connect with the current
ownership who's been running it since
and they're you know later in life
flying them up to maine showing them
what we're doing
telling them we want to bring this to
north carolina we want to reinject the
soul back into this community and back
into this company and back into the
people
in in them and him knowing that he
doesn't have the energy for it anymore
he just doesn't have the capacity he has
the passion for it but
it doesn't he can't physically do it and
seeing that there's another generation
who's going to carry on what he's built
i mean brought tears to his eyes so it
was a
it was an opportunity that
we just can't pass up on
and
it's going to be good man looking
forward to it
[Music]
anything else
nah echo charles you got any questions
what's your cognitive
scenario particularly like what oh
what are you losing yeah like memory or
just gathering words up oh for real yeah
i've always been very
like
sharp i can put i can piece words
together you know and i can throw him
off the tongue but uh sometimes i get
caught up and i never get caught up you
know and someone says oh isn't it just
age you're 42 now yeah i don't know
about that when i'm when i drink this
stuff no when i'm drinking the go you're
on fire oh yeah it flows it flows yeah
mm-hmm but uh
i don't have any i don't have any lag in
anything
good all right well probably a good
place to stop and i mean just
the the thing that you just said that
right there that kind of hit
that i think is the unifying thing
is
[Music]
what we're doing
is about the people
it's about the people
it's bigger than
it's infinitely bigger than just
us obviously
it's it's a movement
that resonates with people
the way people think it already is there
you know what i'm saying that's what's
trying to say like about the culture
it's already there and it's not just in
north carolina the people that
this resonates with people with people
it just resonates they understand what
it is we're trying to do they understand
that what
we all are doing including you that's
listen it's like what we all are doing
is the right thing to do it's the right
thing to do is to rebuild america is
is to take care of our communities
is to take care of our families take
care of our friends take care of our
country and to put and the way that you
do that is you take care of people
and you put people above profit there's
so many decisions that got made and at
some point
when we document this whole thing and we
go back and we pick apart decisions that
got made by corporations in this country
where they decided to save four percent
on the production of a pair of jeans or
six percent on the production of a pair
of boots and they took and they ripped
those the rip those capabilities out of
this country for four percent for six
percent
and destroyed communities
to make that money
when we tell that story i think people
already know that and i think that's why
this resonates with people they
understand that what we're doing is the
right thing to do
putting people above profit and by the
way that is not
that is a strategic win
the short-term win is oh we can make we
can save four percent if we ship
everything overseas we get it shipped
overseas or we get it made overseas
that's a tactical win yeah hey we we
made more money this quarter
we made more money this year but what
they did in the meantime is destroy
communities and take away the the
freaking thing that makes america
america and that is the pride in what we
do in this country
so
i think everybody knows that we're doing
the right thing i think that's why so
many people are supporting what we're
doing that's why so many people are with
us
like i don't i feel like it's not just
us it's it's everyone when i meet people
when we you you mentioned the other day
someone was telling you that at the
muster there's everyone's wearing origin
jeans hell yeah they are
yeah that's what's happening and when we
make stuff and they know where it comes
from and they know that it's connected
to other people
this that's why i think this is just a
a train
that's just leaving the station and it's
picking up speed
and it's gonna roll
hell yeah
that's where i think we're at echo
charles all right so echo uh
[Music]
how do we get on board this train train
well you gotta do the right thing
you know speaking of doing the right
thing so we'll talk about okay you
mentioned discipline go right helping
you with your yeah you know your brain
that's jocko go
yeah yeah that's brain fuel brain fuel
that's the morning brew right there so
that's essentially doing the right thing
in honesty in a smaller kind of more
specific way where you know we need our
energy drinks some people drink coffee
and i dig it
some people they drink energy drinks but
you know you're not doing the right
thing a lot of time when you're drinking
like a normal energy you mean a sugary
snack that
makes you feel like [ __ ] yeah later yeah
i never drank energy drinks oh for i did
i i've had a sip of uh
a familiar
popular drink once never drank energy
drinks but i heard about kids dying from
those you know drinks i was like hell no
yeah never let my kids either now i love
i left them of course because it's good
for you that's the test that's the do
you let the kids drink it i do yep
too yeah so in fact my kids kind of get
nuts with it yeah
i'll say i don't know speaking of uh of
profit before people and um i i don't
know how much profit we're losing
because of my kids and their
freaking nuts yeah yeah these kids are
rocking yeah yeah they they
i didn't i didn't realize it's gonna be
so popular with with kids you know
teenagers athletes all that stuff has
it's been awesome yeah it's the new it's
essentially the new uh what paradigm is
that the right word actually i shouldn't
ask you anymore um what did you want to
catch his vocabulary his brain
but in this group my brain's working
just fine
but yeah so it's a new era of energy
drinks we don't have to worry about that
kind of stuff anymore we don't have to
worry about our kids dying anymore
actually it'll you drink two of those
you're more healthy technically yeah
it's insane stuff electrolytes
everything boom just in there in there
so yeah that's one of the things you can
do man get on the down line
the cool thing is you're doing like
you're doing something good for yourself
and you're helping out the world in the
world
tactical and strategic that's true 100
across the board also speaking of doing
the right thing do the right thing for
your joints so you know joint uh how
should i say maintenance it's not as
sexy it's like an energy drink or even
molk or something like this you want to
know what's not sexy limping around
that's not it's true it's true but it's
like you know one of those things but we
gotta pay attention and do the right
thing yeah so you get the joint warfare
the super krill oil keep your joints in
the game and see this you just said
subscription you know you kind of like
we're starting to go down that path but
this is the one
in my opinion
this is where you subscribe because you
don't want to
get caught short without
what you need yeah and it's not like
you're waking up in the morning craving
some krill oil or something like this
like you might be like hey i'm kind of
craving the discipline go you can find
yourself in that kind of situation but
the joint warfare you don't crave that
but you need though unless you don't
take it
yeah you crave it i yeah
religiously i was with life and i were
down with the monster and so we do these
we do we do workouts at the muster you
know and they're burpees and you know
you and you're
they're just a little bit different
right yeah and uh so we and we do them
so we show up for the muster before the
muster actually starts and we do the pts
to kind of test them out make sure
they're good to go
how we're going to do where we're going
to do them like
and you know so we did a bunch of
burpees and jump squats or whatever one
day and something like that and life and
i we have like a room that's connected
you know because we're working
and
like whatever day two of us being down
there he's like bro
he texts me about this he goes he goes
hey you got joint warfare
i was like bruh this is not amateur
what's up baby goes i didn't break goose
i i because he has a go bag right yeah
and he travels with it but you got to
reload your go bag failure to reload
and i was like hey man
i got bad news for you i got some
for myself i didn't bring enough for
other people oh no because that's how i
do my loadout my loadout did we
overnight himself
i don't know what he did he might have
gone to the vitamin shop yeah i don't
know
i couldn't yeah it was uh it was rough
but that's the kind of situation you
want to be no right you know so let's
not let that happen because he's in
there freaking limping around holding
his back and
that sucks
yeah
it makes you a believer though oh if you
don't take it you also know you know
that was a classic
leaf was like bro
that's our topic you know our whole
company you combine everything together
apparel footwear geez supplements
everything
joint warfare is our number one selling
item
every day yeah we
like
america is addicted to joint warfare
it's freaking good it's all good for you
so good for you all right so what else
what else echo charleston oh speaking of
good for you immunity
this is vitamin d can we talk luck here
for a second sure
okay uh rewind pre-covered
belittle like hey jocko what do you
think about vitamin d i take it every
day oh do you want to make some
i was like yeah let's do it this is
pre-coveted
let's do it okay
hey while we're doing that let's make
immunity because i travel and i get on
planes and i shake hands with a bunch of
people and you know they're passing you
the freaking all kinds of germs and
whatnot
let's make an immunity thing cool okay
so we make two things cold war and
vitamin d pre-covered yeah pre-covered
good timing god that was
that was epic man again this is this is
you know just luck grace of god uh god's
a frog man whatever you want to say
that is just perfect yeah and so
we and we bought a decent amount of it
we we stocked up on a decent amount of
it and then as soon as covet hit
people are literally telling people to
take exactly like vitamin d and the
uh half the ingredients that are in in
uh cold war yep so that was awesome and
again luck timing
grace of god you know a little bit
everything will take it i think you when
you're moving in the right direction
without compromise and you're in tune
when you're in tune then
you know [ __ ] just happens i feel like
we're in tune with
not just our customers but we're in tune
with what america needs
you know what's weird i was talking to
maine tai today and
i was saying sometimes i make myself
nervous right because i like i'm very
particular in what i like
and there certainly is no guarantee that
anyone else in the world is going to
like what i like
and and this podcast is a great example
there's been many times where i've been
creating or reading or preparing a
podcast and i'm thinking to myself this
is pretty much going to be for an
audience of one
the only person that is going to have to
suffer through what i'm doing right now
that's what's going to happen
and and i'm wrong because
there are other people
that
think the exact same way and and that's
what i said about like the about the
discipline go drink he says he says
isn't it isn't it weird he said i heard
you talking about why didn't anybody
else make this and i think
for me
i think
it's crazy to me that no one would make
an energy drink that's good for you
that's not sweetened with sugar that
doesn't have any that's pasteurized it's
crazy me to think that no one would and
sometimes when i think of these things i
think i might be thinking for an
audience of one like oh if i could have
that i would do it right and so
but but
then you test you know you you put it
together and you put it out there and
you realize this is the most this is the
best thing about all this stuff
everything that we're doing
the best thing about it is you realize
we're not alone i'm not alone you're not
alone we're not alone there's a bunch of
people on the path
that want to be better that want to help
america that want to take vitamin d3
that want coal like there's a bunch of
people that want a stronger immune
system
this shouldn't seem like a shock yeah
right there's a bunch of people that
want genes that are made in america
iconic american genes that aren't even
made in america what is that stop
and so it's very nice
sometimes for me to realize at certain
moments that there's that we're in this
together yeah
it's true yeah speaking of being in this
together milk we're on them on the milk
train together so that's the good one
right extra protein additional protein
of dessert you did a good job with that
one guys real good job with the taste
the milk yeah got to get some of that
more providing all those milkshakes at
camp this week
vitamin shop wawa jackalful.com if you
subscribe to it chippings free that's
look look are we competing against some
heavies
you know are we 135 pounds in the open
bracket going in against the heavies
yeah we are yeah
they got some advantages
and so we got to figure out how we're
going to counter some of those
advantages one of the things that some
of these big players including the
biggest players in the game can do is
they can ship stuff for free because
they're absorbing costs they're making
money on other areas and so they figure
out how to ship stuff for free
and so you and i had this conversation
you're like bro we gotta we gotta figure
this out and i'm like hey man this is
america
like people don't wanna pay for shipping
and you're like brainstorming i heard
freaking spark plugs going off and
you're noggin
a week later you're like bro if we can
get people if people subscribe engine
i was thinking more like a two
horsepower
i was looking for a lawnmower
but hey what you know what it produced
because like two weeks later you're like
listen i ran the numbers if people
subscribe we can ship for free we can
ship for free and that's how we can do
it and like awesome so if you are out
there and you want us to ship for free
which we want to do subscribe to one of
these things and everything's all the
shipping is for free that allow that
gives us the advantage
an actual advantage
in the open match against the
heavyweight monsters that are out there
that want to smash us by the way they
want nothing more than to smash oh yeah
when you start eating people's market
share they they're not happy about that
they don't like it
so there you go what else what else we
got well this may seem surprising but a
company called origin usa good company i
hear good things it's pretty good yeah
so
like you said hey if you're gonna get
iconic american stuff
but you get it with either materials
from overseas or they're made overseas
it kind of defeats the purpose a little
bit we can't even call that iconic
anymore and we definitely can't call it
american
it's very hard it's very hard yeah but
when you're making stuff that's made
with literally the seeds of the cotton
that's grown all done in america that's
right all the way to the i love the way
you say cotton yeah that's how that's
how it's said everything there's two
there's two t's in cotton
by the way
it's not caught in i guess it's not zero
t
i guess you're right i think it's cotton
yeah i feel like you guys are right
about me being right in this case i
talked a lot about things that are right
and wrong that thing is not right the
way you say cotton
the cotton is grown here in america
and the jeans
come out on the other side iconic
american delta 68 genes finally got some
thanks pete
nonetheless got something so yes virgin
usa you like that kind of stuff this is
where you can get that kind of stuff not
to mention jiu-jitsu stuff that's why
you guys started after jiu-jitsu stuff
best keys in america you the people have
this in the world sorry about the fact
that the best years in the world
but people everywhere even you today
it's a beautiful thing yeah we found the
last living unicorn herd and we skinned
them and we made these
i was looking for and people would be
like they killed the unicorns
bro i have this couch at my house
and i forget what the material is but
it's like this gray kind of um
uh no it's not velvet
i don't know what it is it might just be
leather
but
but it's great it's green it's kind of a
big couch right and so it's a
brontosaurus so my son was over with his
girlfriend and they were in my girl my
son's girlfriend's like really nice
super sweet girl very nice
and you know we're sitting on the couch
we're watching ufc or something like
this and you know all of a sudden she's
like
saying the couch is comfortable or my
son's like oh this couch is so awesome
because it's a relatively new couch
so she goes yeah this couch is so nice
she goes what's it made of and i go oh
it's baby whale skin
she's got the most horrified look on her
face bro
i had to like immediately say no i'm
kidding because she was about to cry
yeah baby whale skin she was like
yeah so there you go
and it kind of like looks like it could
be
unicorn
skin
like the skin it kind of seems like that
could be the case that's how like
luxurious it is it's luxurious you kind
of can't go back i was looking for an
electric blanket you didn't remember
last year here that kind of cold so
just there bear with me
hawaiian so i'm looking for my big
electric blanket and i end up pulling
out this bin like i could be in there
and it's like my old geese and bro i
touched the old guy i'm not gonna say
the brand yeah and we don't gotta
do that but i touched that guy and i was
like brian i could never put that thing
on it's like sleeping with sandpaper
yeah it's like comparatively speaking
yeah once you go you can you kind of
can't go back you know original usa.com
if you want to get some of this stuff
it's true good stuff on that one also
jacqueline store joco is a store called
jocko's store that's where you can get
t-shirts
hoodies hats that say discipline equals
freedom
jocko podcast you see pete wearing
juggle podcast shirts from time to time
i wear those shirts a lot yeah i wear
that green get after it one-on-one well
yeah yeah some good stuff on there we
also got subscription situation too free
shipping as well
you get a cool new shirt like this one
different designs a little bit more
creative
got the next one is the homage to the
sea wolves oh damn if you like the sea
wolves some of us do scramble seawolves
yeah yeah it's really outstanding it's
all like jocko's that's what i like i
like
let's move in that direction of
[Music]
of the shirts on the shirt locker
representing
that aspect
yeah i like the podcast
yep so yeah jocklestort.com if you like
something hey get something uh subscribe
to this podcast wherever you listen to
podcasts
leave a review
if you want leave a review maybe you
haven't said that in a while leave a
review but no leave a review it's cool
because a we get to read them you can
give us some input b if you read i
haven't done this in a long time maybe
but if you write a really funny one well
i'll read it on here whatever
um also don't forget jocko unraveling
podcast with myself and dc daryl cooper
grounded podcast warrior kid podcast for
the warrior kids out there we also have
the jocko underground look we don't
control this platform
we don't whatever platform you're
listening on we don't control it unless
something you're listening on the
underground jackal underground.com that
we control
so we set up just just to make sure that
things don't go awry
we set up our own little platform
jockowunderground.com
you are helping us fund that
by by subscribing to it it costs eight
dollars and 18 cents a month that's how
you help us build that platform
and maintain
that platform and we will be there in
the event of an emergency in case of a
real bubonic black plague or in case of
censorship or in case of free shadow
shadow banning all the stuff that's out
there
if you can't afford it it's cool we want
you in the game we're not trying to like
exclude anybody if you can't afford it
no factor email assistance at jocko
underground.com and uh we'll get that
taken care of we have a youtube channel
uh it's called the jocko podcast channel
yeah oh yeah it's verified is that the
thing that's how you know yeah yeah the
same deal yeah oh you like that feeling
pretty good about that one i feel good
that you verified i i feel good oh what
what do you mean on instagram no no
you're not no i'm not i don't know you
got to work on that are you there's only
how do you work on that i'm not verified
oh okay i only have no that's for like
whatever followers on instagram
no but it's not about the number of
followers it's not about the number of
followers it's just like if you're like
a what do you call like a public figure
like jocko oh like you are no no no no
no like you bro so like a celebrity
no no no i'm not bro i'm not we're
feeling that's so funny funny little
little blue check mark
yeah it is kind of like a phenomenon
though all right let's lays back on
track get the blue check mark like jocko
has yeah on twitter too by the way yeah
and it's kind of like oh thank you more
soon
yeah yeah
part of the glitterati
whatever do i sense jealousies from no
no no no no no remember when you uh no
jocko fuel we got verified that's
literally i gotta i gotta work on origin
we haven't we haven't tried yet maybe
call it jocko origin it'll get verified
[Music]
i'm gonna change my instagram
if you want to follow like a lot of this
stuff that we're talking about also
origin usa
the the youtube channel that's another
uh another awesome thing to check out
yeah you do uh main tie and the team
puts together
yes once a week yeah generally weekly
now okay see that's just
totally total inside look at what what's
going on yeah it's awesome and uh maine
tai showed up at origin saying can i
work here and you said what skills do
you have and he was like
and he said can you sweep floors he said
yup and now he's running media media
manager so check out what maintains
self-taught
does some good work doing good work even
approved by echo charles over there
uh so subscribe to those things we got
psychological warfare i made an album
it's got tracks on it i'm going to tell
you in your moments of weakness not to
be weak and some some pragmatic reasons
why that's not going to be a good call
what if like you're about to like pound
like a half a container of baklava like
is that like something i don't have one
for you i'm saying because there's
positive reinforcement there yeah yeah
it's like kind of like it's kind of
it's hard uh flipsidecanvas.com
my brother dakota meyer making cool
stuff to hang on your wall we got a
bunch of books i got a new book coming
out called final spin
available for pre-order right now and in
fact
the
yeah i just got done recording the audio
there's i i read the audio i was gonna
have actors and actresses
do the audio but then when you see the
book and you read the book you'll be
like doesn't fit because the book is
just sparse and raw and bare and and
confrontational almost in its approach
and so having a bunch of actors and
actresses wasn't like that so i just
read the whole thing myself so final
spin
pre-order that i had a bunch of i've had
a bunch of people at camp that
preemptively apologized to me when they
give me a book to sign because it's
second edition third a dish whatever
brutal they feel bad look i don't want
you to feel that bad about it
but let's face it we both know that you
hesitated at the moment so get that
first final spin leadership strategy and
tactics field manual the code the
evaluations the protocols discipline
equals freedom field manual weigh the
warrior kid one two three and four mikey
the dragons about faced by hackworth
been signing that one lately
which is cool extreme ownership and the
dichotomy of leadership
that i wrote with my brother leif babin
echelon front speaking of late batman we
have a leadership consultancy we solve
problems through leadership go to
echelonfront.com
if you
want help inside your organization with
leadership
that's also where you can find the
details for our live events
including the muster including field
training exercises including ef
battlefield
next muster is las vegas
it's it's out it's not on the strip of
las vegas
it's at a place called the red rock
hotel
and so it's not it's not one of those
situations where you go and it's oh
we're just gonna party it's not like
that it's separate so it's like a 20
maybe a 30 minute drive
so
most of you don't want to come out and
party anyways but if you want to bring
like your company out there and you're
thinking i don't want to have the issues
of bringing everyone out there it's not
like that
so
that's what we're doing the next one
that's the next muster it's in las vegas
october 28th and 29th
i also have online training extreme
ownership academy what's cool is
something people from origin everybody
everybody's awesome
that's really a lot of our success and
alignment with our our management team
middle management number management is
getting on there my wife is
a savage about it like if you miss a
training
like
some serious [ __ ] better happen in your
life
like straight up why weren't you on the
training
she's she's
you know i've
talked through amanda i talked amanda
through a few situations you know like
over the years of hey this is what's
going on she's like hey can you can you
give me a call and talk to me about this
and i think what she realizes is all
that information that i've given her
personally
is also available to everybody on your
team and everybody who ever wants to
sign in and what a incredible way the
thing about leadership is it's really
easy to get distracted and go to your
your primordial instincts of how you
think you should act and and that's
wrong in many cases it's wrong
so getting that leadership primer every
you know every couple times three times
a week four times a week checking in
seeing what's going on and getting that
in your brain it's so freaking good for
you so that's why it's awesome your wife
is in the game um go to extreme
ownership dot com and if you want to
help service members active
retired their families gold star
families
if you want to donate
or get involved in a charity
organization called
americasmightywarriors.org it's run by
mark lee's mom mama lee she's making
things happen she has a huge impact so
check out america's mightywarriors.org
if you want to get involved if you want
to donate and if you want more of my
lagging lyrical lopes very or you need
more of
well
you need more of
echoes
chatter
then
well
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on the gram on facebook echoes
adequate charles i am at jacqueline
compete
unverified
dang is that pete m roberts
i gotta change that i'm just gonna
change it to pete origin um
you think i should do that i don't know
i think you should just use origin usa
i do oh no i do it's my primary yeah so
i think the other one i don't know what
is it but if it's gonna grow like
well my personal one i i do more
personal stuff and then origin is kind
of like so should we even say it right
now the personal one p if it's personal
stuff p dot m dot roberts no i mean it's
when i say personal stuff i like post
like
training stuff yeah you're doing jiu
jitsu stuff but isn't that origin usa
it is but origin usa is going to grow
well beyond me uh
[Music]
you got a little background got it uh do
you have twitter origin bjj yeah are you
into it are you in the twitter game
anymore i mean i get on like once a
month
so not really not really but i mean i
get on there because i get a bunch of
buildup of messages and stuff so
i gotta do that jackalful.com yeah
they're working on a new website for
chocolate
originusa.com yes sir so that's where
we're at did i miss anything
for how to find us
nah
yeah i mean and at this point anyone
that's still listening it definitely
knows where we're at so we're just
talking to like it's talking about an
audience of there's one person that's
working a 48 hour shift in alaska right
now that's like man i hope they keep
talking yeah yeah yeah yeah nothing else
to do so those thanks but uh if you are
still here and everybody that is here
man thanks to all of you thanks for
supporting the cause thanks for
supporting origen and jocko fuel and by
doing that thank you for supporting
america and look everything that we're
talking about
every single thing that we're talking
about what we're doing right now from
the
the podcast that we're doing to the gear
that we're making to the fuel that we're
supplying to the world
zero of this is possible without what
you're doing without your support
and we are all in this together so thank
you and let's freaking go
and
to all our military right there out
there out there right now we are
recording this in august 2021
afghanistan is in a downward spiral
and i do not know what you all are going
to be called to do
but i wish you good luck godspeed and i
know you will not fail your comrades and
arms and i know you will not fail our
country so thank you for your service
and thank you for putting yourselves in
harm's way to protect the freedom that
we enjoy and love here
so thank you and to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics
emt's dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol secret service
and all first responders
thank you for protecting us and keeping
us safe here on the home front
and
anybody else out there
this what we're doing it's not just our
dream this is the american dream
that's what it is
to create to build to work together to
help and support each other
that's what we're doing
to chase and grind and risk and work and
execute
and to turn this dream
our dream your dream into a reality
and to quote
lenny
i can make that work
and we all can do the same thing
we can make this work
and until next time this is pete and
echo and jocko
out